ici aux portes du lycée joseph gaillard
enseignants et agents territoriaux sont
rassemblés pas question de continuer
cette année scolaire avec une
suppression de contrats aidés les
risques seraient trop importants pour
les élèves
je vous donne des chiffres très simple à
la cantine vous avez 400 élèves assis
dans une salle et aucun surveillant
vous avez un surveillant dans
l'établissement pour 200 élèves alors
que vous avez sur le même site quatre
lycées à l'extérieur vous aviez une
équipe de médiation qui étaient là pour
pouvoir régler les éventuels conflits
elle a disparu sous les établissements
sous lesquelles nous sommes mobilisés ce
matin nous avons une quarantaine de
contrats aidés qui ont disparu nous
aimons radio dans les collectivités donc
les agents dit qu'ils sont dans les
établissements scolaires que nous sommes
des premiers arrivés les derniers partis
nous arrivons les premiers ou faire
l'accueil ou faire l'entretien des
locaux pour faire la petite maintenance
des locaux ou préparer les repas de la
cantine et nous sommes les derniers
partis quand il faut fermer tout
l'établissement
il faut vérifier que tout a été
verrouillé et tout est sécurisé
sauf qu'après trois jours de conflit une
forme d'agacement commence à se faire
sentir auprès des élèves
ce matin nous sommes arrivés et le
proviseur est venu dieux qu'il n'y avait
pas de cours qui avait grève et y avait
des plaquettes devant le lycée on nous a
demandé de repartir je me lever à 4
heures je me demande pas à l'eau lycée à
olivet devant le lycée il n'envoie pas
de mots parents hippies disent que le
lycée est fait homme et dorothée chine
et déjà on est bac à la fin de l'année
donc simple voilà quoi mais après ça
nous bloque un peu fait qu'on a un bac
et n'a besoin de le préparer la réussite
des élèves une responsabilité pour ces
enseignants aussi gréviste
alors comment feront ils nous avons
l'habitude d'amener nos élèves à la
réussite les chiffres sont bons aussi
pour l'année scolaire dernière il y a eu
aussi des perturbations il faut bien que
les gens comprennent qu'on se bat non
pas pour nous on se bat pour nos élèves
pour l'un conditions dans lesquelles ils
sortent ils sont donc aujourd'hui on ira
jusqu où on devra aller et on prendra
nos responsabilités en martinique dans
l'éducation nationale
seuls trois sont 80 contrats aidés ont
été reconduits l'année dernière ils
étaient neuf cent vingt